evening
members thank you very much indeed we
are now live good evening welcome to
this strategy and resources committee
meeting on the 9th of November my name
is councelor Mark Darman I'm the
chairman of this committee members we
are streaming this meeting live as well
as recording by being present in the
meeting you're giving your consent being
recorded during each item please put
your hand up to indicate if you wish to
speak I will then invite you at the
appropriate time can I ask members to
avoid approaching the top table I'm sure
nobody will as this could create
interference with cameras and live
stream uh please note that the YouTube
live stream sound recording is dependent
on the correct use of the microphones
therefore can ask that when invied to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off again when
finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible thank you
item two apologies for absence Tara
thank you chairman yes apologies from
received from councel Jennings and
councel spencley is attending as a
substitute for counc CH councel Nick
spenley sorry chairman thank you thank
you very much indeed uh item three
minutes it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 21st
of September found on pages 5 to 16 are
approved as a true and accurate record I
say move do I have a second um councilor
fluka thank you sorry second no I know
I'm asking you to speak um chairman
paragraph uh I be up on page six the
last paragraph um chairman the way this
is written it seems as though uh that I
was opposing uh everything um
chairman what I was actually speaking to
was this was the skate parks um and that
they should be and and that should be
recorded in the minutes I wasn't saying
we should send all of these projects out
because that would be quite full harded
but what I refer to as the skate parks
in particular and I gave the reasons why
so chairman I i' I'd certainly like that
recording and I I have um other issues
as well chairman well I recall that
vividly Council of fluk so I'm sure the
um the minutes can be amended otherwise
it doesn't make sense chairman no that's
fine go ahead and and chairman I've got
two points on pay chairman um the first
one chairman um in response to councelor
Sid's apology I said that I did not
believe it to be sincere and I stand by
that comment chairman and I asked for
that to be put in the minutes but I
noticed that's not there um and I I
think it's important chairman given that
it was it's likely to be considered in
another place but of course the record
is there on the tape um and and chairman
with regards to that councilor Sid
specifically mentions members of the
conservative party but I think chairman
if one listens the tape you'll find that
he was actually disingenuous to some
individual members as well chairman and
and I've I've got one other item on page
eight as well thank you well I'll
address that one councelor fluk um we
had been in contact and I had mentioned
that fact to the committee Clark but as
you're well aware minutes are not
contemporaneous notes and we have the
benefit of the recording and the video
of both meetings so that what your
comments were have been recorded for
posst
ity would you like to move on to your
next point no chairman with respect um I
think that we all understand that
minutes are not the basm contemporaneous
means something else um but nevertheless
chairman I do think chairman that that
it should have been recorded clearly you
and I differ and we will move on but I'm
pleased to to to to say that I know the
this conversation's being listened to
online um and chairman if I can just
move uh quickly to page eight again
chairman um there is a uh a
recommendation there CH chairman or
resolve of this committee which is quite
clear um chairman but since since that
resolve was
agreed um a Mr Harwood white has
actually said in another place chairman
that this role was also to support
corporate project s which we made quite
clear at the time that it wasn't now
that might have been a slip on his part
but
chairman I think the question I'm asking
you is is that resolve correct in the
minutes I believe it is but I think that
perhaps an officer of this Council May
well have missed that um I mean I there
was a debate about this on the basis I
recall the debate councelor fluka I
don't remember it um specifically but I
think if we can um can we review that um
Miss bird so that we can make sure that
that particular point is as it was said
on the night please but of course CH
chairman with respect I actually believe
that committee services in in in in the
good hands of Miss bird uh has recorded
this correctly uh I'm not saying I I
think the minute's wrong I think the
minute's absolutely right but what
concerned me was that it may not have
been because an officer's misinterpreted
it elsewhere but I'll I'll leave that to
you as well but again that's all been
recorded for SP thank you very much
anything else councelor
fluka no no nothing else so I'm looking
for a proposal to accept the minutes
with subject to the Amendments that's uh
seconded by Council
Sid those in favor please
show thank you very much that's
carried right we now move
to Declarations of interest to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosure
able thank you members thank you the
nature and dis of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other registerable
interests and non-reg interests relating
to items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix be of the code of conduct for
members and members you are reminded
that you are also required to disclose
any such interests as soon as you become
aware should the need arise through the
meeting um do we have any notice of any
public par
participation no chairman we have none
okay thank you so that takes us on to
our first report of the
evening which will
be sorry councelor lagen thank you J
could you my attendance please be noted
in the minut yes of course yes thank
you
um okay so the next item item six half
yearly treasury management update this
is found on pages 17 to 34 of your pack
and we are considering the report of the
interim Chief finance officer Miss Lucas
thank you chair um so yeah the purpose
of the report is to consider the
council's investment activity for the
first half of the financial Year
20223 sorry 23 24 um in accordance with
the chartered Institute of Public
Finance and acces treasury management
code and the council's own treasury
management policy and
practices uh the recommendation in the
report is that just members note the
report for compliance
purposes at section three of the report
we summarize the key issues um so as I
mentioned the code requires authorities
to report on the performance of the
treasury management function at least
twice a yearly um so this is the first
of those at midyear point and there will
be um a year end report as
well the council's treasury management
strategy for this fin finial year was
presented to this committee on the 26th
of January 2023 and was subsequently
approved by the Council on the 22nd of
February during the financial year so
far the council's had an average of 32.3
million PS invested and has been exposed
to financial risks um as is the case
with any financial investments which
could potentially include the loss of
any invested funds um and the impact of
changing interest rates so the purpose
of this report is to cover that activity
and the associated monitoring and
control of those
risks as members will be aware the
council is currently debt free Although
our expenditure plans for the year do
include the acquisition of new waste
Vehicles as part of the Contra the waste
contracts and that will be financed via
internal borrowing for this year and
that was approved at Council on the 30th
of
March uh the council currently engages
link group to provide its treasury
management consultancy and advice
services and appendix 1 um there's a
summary of that information providing an
overview of the external economic
environment so moving on to paragraph
3.4 um the investment activity for the
year um as I've um said to this
committee before the um guidance
requires the council to have due regard
to the security and liquidity of its
treasury investments before it seeks the
optimum rate of return or
yield over the period of um the first
half of the year the council seen an
increase in its Investments of around
4.8 million um and that's due to
primarily timing of um receiving grants
and business rates um before they are
paid out to the beneficiaries and pre
and preceptors so the total held at 30th
of September was 37 million and the
breakdown of those Investments at that
date is set out at table
one so moving on to paragraph 3.5 the um
performance of The Authority in terms
terms of its um rate of returns so over
the first half of the year um the
investment returns averaged 2.6% which
is slightly lower than the 3% assumed in
the budget however as members will be
aware in interest rates have been
increasing over that period and it is
forecast that the average interest rates
over the course of the year um will be
higher than the
3% um in terms of what that equates to
in cash terms we budgeted for um a
return of £750,000 this financial year
we're currently projected to overachieve
that by around half a million
pounds there's more detail in terms of
the interest rate forecasts that have
been provided by Link at appendix two of
the
report so finally just to mention
compliance with the council's pred
presedential
indicators um I can confirm that all of
the presedential indicators have been
complied with to date um except for the
um brief exceptions that are noted um at
table two in terms of the amount of um
cash that the council holds in its own
bank account which um were briefed on um
a few occasions during the year and that
that's detailed within the
report so in summary um yeah this report
provides um an overview of the treasury
management activity during the first
half of the year um and as I just
mentioned um the council has generally
been compliant with its credential
indicators with the um exception of the
um bank balance being slightly overrun a
couple of occasions um I'm happy to
answer any questions members may have
thank you members you'll be aware this
is a um requirement that we get this
report twice at least twice yearly uh
we've seen it plenty of times before and
we're being asked to note the report for
compliance purposes but M Lucas is happy
to take any questions please
indicate councilor
fluka I'll happily give way to these
wise sages
if question
you were the first to indicate um
chairman through you I just wondered if
uh I mean this is always quite a strange
report really and and bearing in mind
what the recommendation is but chairman
I think nevertheless there should be
there should be challenge for members
with regards to um our investment
strategy um firstly chairman um I'd like
to ask that given that this uh Committee
in its when it used to be called
something else um was advised by uh our
financial advisers to invest in
Icelandic Banks I remember it was uh it
was Peter Elliot who uh said that wasn't
a good idea and he was certainly proven
right um I just wanted to be hear from
the section 151 officer and ask for her
to confirm that they are satisfied with
the security and liquidity of the
council's investment strategy and in
particular regards to the lamet property
fund
um chairman I'm I'm quite happily take
an update on the lamit property fund uh
from the1 officer but if in advance of
that chairman I would say that it fell
by 1.5%
today and that over the last 12 12
months it's Fallen by uh I think
14% um so I'm particularly interested in
in that that we are happy with the
liquidity of that I I I never know how
up to date these figures are but I do
think it's important that we you know we
understand where our money is invested
and and of course I suppose that link
link give their advice uh caveated where
whereby they're not responsible if it if
if their recommendations don't perform
as well as they suggest they should um
chairman I have got another question but
I'm maybe it's best if we have an answer
to that first thank you yeah M
lcas thank you thank you councelor fluka
um so as members will be aware any
invest m is never 100% um secure um and
there's always an element of risk with
any Investments but I am satisfied that
the
um council's um approach to investment
is in line with the strategy which
ultimately is not set by me as section5
officer but is agreed by the council as
part of its treasury management strategy
so that was agreed by the um this
committee and by Council in February as
I mentioned at the start of the report
so I'm satisfied that the Investments
are in line with with the council's
strategy and I would just comment that
as um in terms of overall risk approach
I think this Council has taken a
reasonably risk averse approach to its
Investments and the majority of them are
very low risk indeed so um that would be
the first point um in terms of the lamit
um property fund um as I point out in
the report at paragraph
3.5.1 um the average return on that fund
um is 4.2% at the moment um I would have
to take away um we have got the detail
sitting behind the um Trend and
performance of that fund and I could
provide that detail outside the meeting
but obviously that fund is linked to um
property values um so that can fluctuate
over time but the purpose of that um
investment in that fund is to hold it
for the longer term so with any fund of
that type there will be fluctuations in
value um you know during the year and
perhaps over um a number of years but
the purpose of that is to deliver a an
investment return over a longer period
and and again in line with the council's
investment strategy there's only a small
proportion of the funds um of the
council's monies are invested in those
kinds of funds um
but as a balance to that the investment
on those funds is generally higher than
those that's achieved through short-term
Investments so it is about having that
balanced portfolio of risk and return
for the
council Council F next
question
um can you put your microphone on please
sorry I turn it um 3.3.1 chairman um
we're talking here about uh the new
waste contract uh and a necessity to
borrow internally to um um service alone
presumably for these new vehicles um
chairman it came to note uh I can't
remember if it's this week or last week
but those um I'm sure you've got one the
green bins chairman waste spins that we
recycle I'm sure you were as astounded
as I was to find out that they produce a
profit a surplus of £400,000 a year so
perhaps the 151 officer if they're
looking for somewhere to fund these
vehicles we should look to those good
people who pay all that money for their
green bins to fund the corporation dust
carts chairman um so I know that that
doesn't necessarily fit within this
report but I hope that the1 officer
takes my comment comments on board and
and we look forward to that report uh
coming to council chairman when we
discuss the fees and charges and in
particular the charges for those green
bins which appear to generate a huge
amount of money thank you uh councelor
fluka you will be pleased to hear that
that very subject has been discussed by
the finance working group and will
become part of its recommendations this
committee will hear on the 23rd of
November is that special no it is the
next uh SNR
meeting yeah councelor stamp yeah thank
you chair um I'm not afraid of asking
silly questions as I think many of you
know by now but um the section
3.4.3 and it says the council's 5
million of extremely managed pulled and
prosperity fund and has generated a
total return of
203k to date um what is going to happen
is that going to stay in that fund will
it get get reinvested could that bunny
I've read after and it says you can
withdraw it at a notice period but what
is the council's strategy on profits
that are made Within These uh
Investments that's the first one uh and
the second one when I've read the link
group appendix 2 and I just written on
the top of it what can we do about it is
if if if you who's having meetings about
where our money is invested is it at at
your level uh Miss Lucas or is it the
fund managers how does this Council know
exactly where our funds are being
invested what Assurance have we got that
they're ethical are we moving with the
the policy and the way this Council
wants to progress now we've got a new
leadership team just those sorts of
general questions I I'm I'm sorry I do
have a quizy mind and and I'd like to
know a little bit more information I'm
not against what is on these papers but
I do like to understand more what I'm
actually voting on thank you I'm sure m
lcas cuz he's going to tell you that our
investment strategy is set by the um our
investment strategy um committee so miss
Lucas would you like to working group um
so yeah as I said previously thank you
chair um the strategy is actually um set
by this committee and then approved by
Council so the the strategy um will be
considered again in January of this year
um and the parameters of what the
council invests in um are set out within
that so um you could refer back to that
strategy doent for this year and
officers then invest monies during the
year to ensure compliance um with that
um and in terms of the the pulled and
property funds that is in line with our
current agreed strategy if members
thought that they perhaps wanted to
change strategy um it's within their
gift to reconsider that uh in January
again
CH can I come back are you m does it
thank you chair does it come back as the
individual figures because I think it'd
be really interested if I could see
you're getting 23,000 or whatever it is
on such and such looking at the the
financial concerns we've got at this
council at the moment it might be worth
taking it out so our services aren't
reduced or or whatever decisions we're
going to be taken and I think it could
be discussed at the finance committee so
if I go back because I've got all the
documents CU you know I'm like a print
it off if I go back and find it it will
tell me where individ our funds invested
will it and how much returns we get so
the purpose of this report and the the
the midyear report and the year end
report is to give that detail so um yeah
that the the detail of where our money
is invested as I said is set out at
table one um and the Returns on those um
Investments is reported um essentially
as part of this this report the the
strategy itself would not um go to that
level of detail in terms of where
individual um uh Investments are made
but it will set out categories of types
um of um Investments that the council
was prepared to invest in so for example
the limits in terms of how much money it
would put in in
um as to say managed property funds or
into um money market funds so there's
there's limits on the categories and the
Investments but within that then there's
some officer delegation to then invest
in accordance with that during the
during the financial year one
last chairman it's important lot of
people are watching this lot of people
watching this abely fine I think you've
made me forget what I was going to say
now oh for goodness sake when you get to
hang on it's gone it was about it'll
come to me chairman sorry you you
interrupted me you can't you can't
interrupt we
for okay yeah I think it's important to
realize that
we our investments have to be over very
short periods of time because we don't
have large balances to invest longterm
we get a a big intake of money when the
council tax is paid but of course we
have to then keep paying it out to
everybody else so the fact that we might
have 30 odd million invested doesn't
actually mean we've got 30 million
that's ours so we we're just having to
shove it backwards and forwards until we
have to pay it out so I'm going to to
councelor driver first thank you chair
um and you might possibly have answered
my question we'll see on page
34 of um report appendix
3 uh I note that the council has adopted
a voluntary measure of its exposure to
liquidity risk and that actually it sets
itself a target of 3
million uh total cash available within
three months and actually we've got 25
million and I'm just wondering whether
actually well two two issues surrounding
that one is whether actually we're
getting as much return as we could do if
we're sitting on a hell of a lot of cash
but it might well be councelor Durham uh
your what you've just said might be the
answer but I'll yeah wait for M Lucas to
goes out with r and Ben and all sorts
but miss Lucas um yeah so as I mentioned
with in the report the primary concerns
are for security first so that the
investment is safe and liquidity so
we've got adequate cash available to
manage what we need to throughout the
financial year um and as the chair said
that does fluctuate quite significantly
during the year as we receive
significant amounts accounts tax and
business rights which we have to
redistribute
um having said that obviously there is a
um a measure as it says in the in that
appendix around um the target for cash
availability which is significantly
lower than the amount of cash um that we
have available within that 3month period
there are other interacting measures um
as I said in terms of what we are
allowed or what we agree as a council we
want to invest in so um the majority of
our investments are in easily accessible
accounts such as money market funds um
and there is a balance between as I say
the kind of um return we get on those
Investments and and the length of those
Investments it may be as our cash
balances are continuing to grow that we
might look to potentially um put some
more money in longer term um Investments
if the strategy allows and if we feel
that we we don't need that cash in the
short term but the primary the primary
concern is that we always have enough
cash available to to meet the council's
needs can I come back to very quickly uh
well I understand that it's just really
it's a judgment call really as to
whether that amount of cash given the
target of 3 million and we've got a cash
there of 25 if it really was to
fluctuate enormously then it might be
just a point in time but actually if
that's carried over some period of time
and we we're sitting with a lot of cash
then we're not going to be getting you
know the return that might be possible
and I note early on that we're we're
slightly under what where we hope to be
I heard your point about over the year
we will probably hit the 3% or or Beyond
which would be positive but anyway it's
a it's a it's a I I I hope you will take
that away and just consider it thank
you Council yeah come to council bound
councilor Stan you remember what you
were going to say
councilor I don't want to label the
point but um uh going back to this table
here on 342 it's just that it seems a
generalization to me of the Investments
and you're saying you do take a prudent
approach to the Investments but we're
not being told specifically where it is
guilt and other things and uh how much
is cash and property or whatever and I
just thought we might have bit more
detail where these Investments are and
where might be more ones we might be
more exposed to risk is that not
possible or have I miss
something um so as I say we we don't
currently in the report detail every
single investment however the categories
of investment that we do um report on at
table one um do give an indication of um
the liquidity of those kind of
Investments and um so in terms of the
the first one for example Banks and
building societies as you'll be aware
that's kind of cash which is instantly
available generally money market funds
again are instantly available um so they
are yeah they are short-term and again
debt management um account with the
government um those funds are you know
extremely liquid they can be withdrawn
at short notice so in terms of um
Investments that aren't um liquid if you
like it's um primarily the fixed term in
deposits with the local authorities
which is the fourth line um and the
longer term investments that we detail
um at
3.4.3
um I officers have delegated authority
and responsibility for making those
Investments as long as it's in line with
our investment
strategy councilor white uh thank you Mr
chairman M's just a generalization
really and um it's just to say that
everybody's been doing molden District
Council down on their finances and and I
think these are relatively positive
although it's shortterm money it's not
money that's actually you know going to
stay longterm um but I mean we we trade
on the lme and um in in relation to
everything that's been going on with
local councils I think we should be very
careful on in investing in other local
authorities because all the ones we were
held up to admire haven't they've sort
of failed spectacularly um and I think
it's a good job that we do go for
sensible safe options that maybe have a
lower interest return rather than the uh
big returns because obviously they're
they're risky as we all know so I'm
happy for us to be prudent um are the
new homes bonus included in these I
presume they are are
they um through you chair um so I I'm
not entirely clear apologies of of of
the question I mean in terms of the cash
that the council has available new homes
bonus is one Grant stream of a number of
income streams that the council has so
um you know in aggregate the council
will be holding monies relate to a whole
different number of income streams at
any point in time but um you know it's
not possible to um disaggregate where
those income streams specifically are
invested it's it's managed as a total um
cash fund of the
council if I might come back it's just
that um we've had a a big increase in
the new homes bonus obviously um because
times have been good and there's been a
lot of building but these streams are
going to dry up I suspect with the
downturn um and and it's just I was just
interested to see how much of the nhb
had been um invested but that's that's
that's something I can do another day I
could do that via email thank you I
think as you're aware counselor why the
new homes bonus is included in our Yeah
in our MF
now yeah
okay I'm going to give you one last time
councilor St yeah thank you chair um I
i' actually do think we need to be
cautious and I was very aware you've
just said it's under office of
Delegation about our investments and
everything and I think you and have to
look at the number of councils who are
experiencing financial difficulty and I
think as members it is our right and our
duty to question it and those delegated
decisions that go through the Section
151 of is the leader involved in in any
of that as well all right well well
maybe when it comes to our strategies
again I think we maybe need to actually
look at that I'm not casting any
aspersions I'm looking at what's
happening generally here and I think we
need to just be cautious of all the
weight of somebody having that control
just a personal I I think it's fair to
comment councelor stamp that officer
decisions relating to Investments of
council money is under more scrutiny now
than it's ever been clearly because
thork that is how thork got into
problems because of its
questionable investment policy so you
know I I have full faith in our offices
to um to to follow the guidelines there
the issues at Thor and other similar
issues have been due to the lack of
member scrutiny into what the officers
are doing which is not the case in this
Authority I think that I think that's
very unfair to the the officer thought
because it was the members actually
agreed to invest in the Solar Farms
whether the officers conducted due
diligence or not to the right level is
for for the inquiry to sort out but that
was you know that was actually a member
decision to I think I think you read the
report Council which has been published
the best value report the majority of
those were taken incorrectly by an
officer who's no longer at that
Authority thank you
um right um councelor
Sidle uh thank you chair uh I yeah as
everybody knows I have no statutory
Powers so yeah and I think in terms of
this and in terms of the questions that
are being asked I think the time to ask
these questions is at the beginning of
the year rather than now so if we want
to change some of these things or look
at how this is invested this isn't the
right time this is just a report that
we're noting and if we want to change
how we might do things what we invest in
you know the finance group or whatever I
think would be the right process to to
to do that through and then through this
committee as normal um yeah so I'm I'm
fully open to those sorts of
ideas yeah the point is taken thank you
councilor Sid um investment decisions
should not be taken individual
investment decisions should not be taken
by members that is what we employ
officers for um who should be experts in
that field you know if if we allow
members to invest our money I I just
hate to think where we be Council of
white then we're going to end this yeah
I was just saying um that I'm happy to
um report this but just to say that um
we should challenge these when they come
up we shouldn't just leave it to the
once a year decision I think it's
important that we we challenge these
every time we see them because sometimes
things happen o over the course of a
period that you're not aware of at the
beginning of the year you know and and
as I said earlier we've been told for
years all these councils like thork and
I think Bon's now in trouble we were
told we were falling way behind them and
suddenly with us out here on this little
Peninsula we're actually not doing too
badly thank you very much I know we've
got problems coming ahead but let's
celebrate the positives of molden you
know we're all part of molden okay thank
you councelor
what you're suggesting is actually what
we're doing and we don't just do it once
a year we we're obliged to do it at
least twice a year so you know that is
the whole purpose of this report which
we are being asked to note members are
you happy to note thank you very much
indeed uh we now move to the next
item which he gets we'll find any second
and that is the rural settlement list
2024 25 again miss Lucas you're back
on I think we'll let the officer present
the report first please thank you chair
so this report um is to propose the
rural settlement list for the financial
year
2425 um which determine and awards rural
rate relief to eligible businesses um
the rural settlement list is attached at
appendix a and it's asked that the
committee approves that um won't cover
the summary of key issues but it is a
requirement um as the report says of the
Local Government Act 1988 that the um
Council does um agree this um and it's
necessary for us as a council to refresh
the policy and um for that this policy
annually and no changes are proposed for
the next financial year so um unless
anyone's got any specific questions
councelor
driver uh thank you chair
um I I don't know whether this has any
bearing whatsoever on uh definitions of
uh settlement size and whether this has
an implication or
otherwise in terms of
planning they may be totally separate
and in which case fine I just ask the
question yeah I think the answer is yes
they are totally
separate
Lucas yeah yes but um obviously the the
the list is reviewed each year in terms
of the size of um the individual
settlements that are listed to make sure
that they're still policy um compliance
so that is that is reviewed in light of
the latest planning figures each
year yeah can I just ask for a slight
more clarification does that mean that
it they are completely separate in terms
of how they're viewed or does this list
have a potential bearing on how we
Define the settlements across
M and
District I apologies but I'm not
entirely clear on um what you're asking
but I it the the policy doesn't affect
the planning decision but the the the
the outcome of any planning decision
potentially does implicate the list of
eligible um settlements for Rural relief
but that this policy itself does not
would not influence any planning
decision counc F and then coun The
Village was to grow above 3,000 then it
wouldn't be exempt anymore but I had a
general question microphone um obviously
if the village was to gr with 3,000 then
it wouldn't be exempt anymore so you
lose that exemption so there is the
level of management there I just a
general question is how do businesses
know that they've got relief is that
something that the The Authority makes
them aware of or do they have to know to
claim
exemption um if I may chair I might um
pass to my colleague um Su green because
I think she might know the answer to
that
one okay thank you chairman um so it is
something that if if the business was
eligible we would certainly make sure
that they were aware but there is an
application process is still needed um
and with regards to the settlement areas
they are reviewed annually with our
policy team um because the boundary for
a settlement isn't
necessarily um the actual
Parish it depending on the nature of
where the houses are situated it is
possible to have more than one
settlement within a town or a parish so
that is determined by our planning
policy team and that is reviewed
annually along with the numbers of
people that live in that
settlement councilor fluka yeah I think
um Mrs Green's almost answered that
because I I was quite curious why why
some of the villages appear twice as
North and South South uh I don't think
any of is east and west but whilst I'm
talking about East and West chairman
southminster is a very very large
um I I I'll say it's a large Ward for
for civil parishes is concerned um but
chairman there's much of it is very very
rural and there are lots of businesses
within the rural area um and perhaps
that might be something that M green
could could could look at uh and see if
there is any way we can give some
support to those businesses that are out
on the marshes uh and do have specific
needs and with regards to uh writing to
businesses that that may um May comply
with with this um I I just mentioned
that the uh one of the public houses in
uh Bradwell on SE uh closed which left
the other one open for 100% relief
chairman and no one contacted them uh I
understand that the the the landlord's
been alerted to this now so we you know
we really ought to be mindful of
that Mr GRE do you want to make a
comment or would we just take on board
those
comments thank you chairman so yes
office so staff will be looking for
eligibility and if there's any changes
and just apologize that that mistake
happened councelor
white thank you Mr chair mine's just a
curiosity just looking at um North fish
north and south and it's just dawned on
me which I I hadn't thought of before um
mland is splitting to two Villages there
mland and mland sea and they're two
different voting areas and two different
Ward areas and yet it appears I could be
wrong they're classing Mand as one one
Village that's
3,100 whatever it is um so how does that
work when North fanbridge which is Tiny
has got a north and south and Bradwell
on sea and Bradwell water side are
separated why are mland and M unless I'm
wrong they look like they're joined
together together which is really odd
and it they're not the same area at all
they may have linked up but they're not
the same area this is
green thank you chairman so yes it is
quite a complex decision that's made and
that's why our our our planning policy
team look at it because there's a number
of factors to to consider um and one of
the main things is actually whether
there is a group of houses that are
specifically in an area that are linked
to um a a single um area so mland for
example because mland has um mland is is
not necessarily having two separate
centers so that so I I wouldn't proport
to be an expert on this because I said
is very complex and it is something that
our planning policy team will look at
and they will as I say they'll look at
the numbers of properties how they are
coalesced around um a specific Center um
so it is as I say it is complex I'm
quite happy if if members would like to
circulate some sort of General guidance
on the sort of things that the planning
policy officers would look at yeah I'm
thinking this needs further explanation
I'm thinking perhaps if we can maybe get
somebody from the planning policy
team to the committee to explain this or
or do it outside in on an individual
basis councelor why I
mean I live in mland so I do have a
little bit of an interest but we what
I'm can't get my head around is we have
two different voting areas in mland
you've got one that I totally accept
that and this is just bizarre when
you've got North fambridge split and
Bradwell split I think this should be
deferred for further this is completely
wrong now I've looked at it in in depth
it's absolutely wrong I I I just this
must be deferred so we have further
information we're not sure if it's wrong
in relation
to the policy that's being applied that
the thing what we don't understand is is
is why they are grouped in in the way
that they are yeah and the
interpretation of it I I think I don't I
don't think we can say that these are
wrong and
and you know not not not consider these
but I think we need more
explanation of how this how this is
arrived at I think before this is signed
off this needs some really detailed
scrutiny and I hope that the ward
members who cover um because I don't
cover them who cover mland and orthorn
actually take this up because this this
is a real problem for me personally
because they're not related at all they
just happen to be next to each
other sure they'll do that councelor
driver uh thank you chair I I might be
misreading this but on
page
37 of this appendix it seems to list the
rural settlement
areas uh and ma doesn't appear to be
there I had assumed it was its it
related to its size and therefore wasn't
defined as a rural settlement area but
maybe I'm
wrong I might come yeah we
yeah the it's sorry it's done on
population I think it's over 3,000 and
what I am a bit shocked about is they've
lumped two completely different
boundaries together to form one massive
Village that that just goes over the
3,000 limit but that you can't one side
of mland doesn't vote with the other
side of mland they're different Wards
they have different voting stations the
mail comes from a different area it's
delivered on different Vans it's
completely different and I think to lump
them together just because they happen
to have joined up I mean hybridge has
got different areas mold's got different
areas north fanbridge which is teeny
tiny has got different areas bre's got
different areas althorne which is Tiny
has got different areas so yeah I'm just
really perplexed I hadn't noticed it
before but obviously it's it's just
scrutinizing it I'm like oh that's
that's yeah yeah I I can see you have a
point councelor Miss White so we um we
will investigate that particular thing
we can chairman I do need to check
because I believe this um this
particular list has to be agreed by the
31st of December um each year so
um I can give members reassurance as I
say this this um this list and the
criteria
are reviewed annually by our policy team
and that will be different policy
offices um so I can give members
reassurance that there will be a you
know a proper process and there will be
due consideration what I can't do is to
give you that level of detail other than
to give you you a professional view that
this has been considered by our our
planning policy team um and that is
their professional view that these are
settlements within those areas okay and
and I'm not going to accept a proposal
that this goes back to the 23rd of
November because that agenda is
absolutely Chu a block and we're going
to be there till midnight that night so
I Council fluka you want to say
something well yes chairman only that of
course we can't be there till midnight
because I'm sure everybody like to go
home at 10:00 but chairman I I look it's
clearly Mrs Green is Keen to move this
forward and we clearly can't consider it
chairman but I would propose that we we
we agree the
recommendation and that members look at
section 47 and local government and
finance act where I think they'll find
all the answers to their questions and
and if indeed they've got any questions
then I'm I'm sure Mrs Green or take them
but there does seem to be some ambigu it
does seem to be I agree but we do need
to move this forward is that a proposal
then councilor
Fluker if you'd like to propose that we
approve this that would be very I think
J if you listen to the tape you you will
hear that I've already done that well
okay then I'm looking for a seconder for
that which is secondly by counselor
sidle those in favor
please two three that is carried thank
you
okay next item on the agenda is the
whistleblowing policy pages 39 to 48
director of strategy and resources
that's Mr
Dodson thank you chair good evening
members um this report presents the
review of the whistleblowing policy and
requests that it should be approved for
a further three years it's important
that the council has in place policies
to protect the council and the public
purse from fraud there are a number of
policies required to do this these being
the antifraud and Corruption policy
anti-money laundering policy and the
bribery act policy all of which were
updated and approved by this Committee
in July of this year to work alongside
these a whistleblowing policy is needed
to ensure a mechanism is in place to
allow employees to confidentially report
any concerns relating to possible fraud
without repercussion this is an
important policy um that we highlight in
the annual governance statement and is a
supporting document in fraud
audits the policy is in place and
although work inadequately had last been
reviewed more than three years ago in
January 2018 by the finance and
Corporate Services committee therefore
an exercise was under taken to review
this and the draft reviewed policy is
attached to appendix one this review was
completed by the assistant director
resources and the draft was reviewed by
the section 151 officer the committee is
asked to review and approve the report
and a further review period will then be
set for three years or earlier if
legislation changes during that period
thank you chair councelor stamp could I
ask a question how many people have
actually used
it
I checked that because I expected that
question that's exactly what I said in
the agenda meeting to Mr Dodson somebody
will ask if any been it hasn't in in the
last three years we've had nobody no no
whistleblowing um incidents through
using the the
policy councilor
spenley thank you chair well since it
was me that raised this back in July I'm
delighted to see that officers have
moved very swiftly to uh renew the
policy I think the next um big question
is how it's rolled out and refreshed in
staff's Minds because as Mr Dodson
rightly said it's a very important
policy and uh in case people think I'm
banging on about this I should explain
why I feel it's a very important policy
before I uh when I retired I spent six
years working in the NHS and for the
last three of those years I was given
the grandos but rather futile title of
freedom to speak up Guardian um and I
have to say the NHS hasn't exactly
covered itself in glory in the
whistleblowing field um and there are
many scandals that we all know about
where failure to actually uh Implement
and support a whistleblowing strategy
has led to uh multiple unnecessary
fatalities so um fortunately we're not
quite in the position of of that level
of risk touchwood um but nevertheless as
the report correctly says the public
purse is at stake
and the Integrity of the
organization um as members uh we we know
that in social media we are accused
frequently of receiving Brown envelopes
and uh
which remains unchallenged largely with
the creditable exception of council
lagen Who robustly challenged it a few
months ago um so so it is a very
important policy so I'm very interested
first of all in how it will be refreshed
and rolled out and really embedded in
the culture of the
organization um secondly um I noticed in
a report in 2018 of the finance and
Corporate Services committee there was
at that stage an annual report on the
policy is this does this continue is
this a A continuing process uh thirdly
um I suppose the question is um what
about members does the report apply to
member conduct and if not what how what
covers member conduct in terms of
whistleblowing um I think that's that's
all I have to ask thank you chair good
questions Mr
doson thank you
chair is reported through the annual
governance statement so so that's where
um it relates to and and the annual
governance statement includes a section
on whether there's been any
whistleblowing um incidents within the
any incident I don't know if that's the
right word but but any any um any use of
the the whistleblowing policy to to make
representations
um the the
new uh service planning process that
we've brought in through that all of
those service heads or assistant
directors should be identifying the
policies within their area and making
sure that the date and the renewal um
review period is on those to make sure
that it's picked up within the the
threeyear
period um and in terms of of rolling it
out we will be um promoting this through
the the one team document to to remind
and inform officers that it is a
document that they need to be aware of
and that they can use appropriately
should should the the the need arise and
yes it does apply to
members thanks I think that I think um
yes good good point it does actually
refer to employees rather than
members
that sorry within the report it does say
on
page 44 that that it is extended to
counselors just Clarity chairman through
you to Mr do I think I didn't actually
pick that up in the actual report in in
the actual policy document so it might
be an idea you know to approve this
chairman and subject to I'm very happy
to approve it and and I think that's a
very key Point actually I had absolutely
no idea that we were included in the
whistleblowing um and I think that needs
to be perhaps communicated to members
that members have the right to
whistleblow in relation I'm assuming
that that works member again member
about member member
about employee employee about member it
has to go each way and I think that the
the protection of being able to make
complaints anonymously is extremely
important and I think members need to
know that and I didn't know at all I I
had actually assumed that if there was a
complaint to be made it you had to you
you had to stand up and be counted but
so I think that's really quite
important so yes yes chair we we can
promote that through the the weekly
member bulletin to make sure that
there's there's a an item that goes on
there to to raise it with members and
I'll have to think about other routes
through which we could yeah raise that
to make sure that that all members are
aware of the the that they are covered
by the the policy as well yeah that's
that's councelor lagen you'd like to
speak at this
committee I will let you it's okay with
the uh approval of committee and
yourself chair thank you um it's a
question does it have to be does it have
to be reviewed every 3 years or going to
be reviewed
sooner
please the the it will be three years
subject to any changes in legislation
that may affect the policy which would
trigger it to be reviewed
earlier I've I've I've read the report
and um it's as Echo counselor spencley
sentiments is a it's a very robust
document the the
only it does seem a little bit
cumbersome in its um um content of the
processes which to go through so there's
a lot of internal um I know there's an
external Avenue that's available if if
somebody wishes to make a complaint they
can make it to a counselor or outside
the council as a function for that um
the only thing I'd say and it's just a
view um in the next review maybe a
simpler type of approach would help you
know these are the steps to take if x y
z and just simplify a fraction but it's
it's good work thank you I think I think
our expert councelor spencley is going
to uh allude
to I wouldn't Define myself as an expert
but um the par paragraph 10f refers to
this external body which is the charity
public concern at work which I think is
also known as protect some authorities
have that as a primary contact uh so
it's just a thought for the future
perhaps
okay okay members I think we're all
reasonably happy so uh do we are we
agreed Thank you very much
indeed okay we now come to any items of
business the
chairman of the committee decides are
Urgent there are none item 10 exclusion
of the public and
press to resolve that under
section4 of the Local Government Act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business on the grounds that they
involve the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph
three of part one of schedule 12a of the
act and this satisfies the public
interest test do I have a proposal for
that okay councilor fluka please go
ahead chairman don't
speak I have asked councilor fluka to
give us a reason why we shouldn't see a
propos better because you did it with
such a heavy heart last time um chairman
I I I I just turned the the the
committee and officers uh attention to
agenda item 11 in particular chairman um
I I think there's been a huge amount of
public interest in this I know that
people seem to think I'm an expert on
the splash park uh and I've had lots of
members of public come to me chairman
but I've I've read read the reports and
and I can't really see anything in there
uh of a confidential nature or anything
that's commercially sensitive I mean
we're we're talking about reworking a
contract with an existing provider um
chairman there's no mention really of
any monies in there and how much we're
going to charge them uh it certainly
wouldn't give we're already negotiating
chairman with the principal so they are
totally aware of where we are chairman
but I think because of the public
interest in this chairman um unless
officers can convince me otherwise I
think should be dealt within public
session and and can I just uh chairman
make a point and I know you'll support
me on this but ordinarily when we bet on
it but you a TR chairman when when we uh
considered items under Section 100a
there was always a reason in the report
why and and I think perhaps chairman if
you're if your members deserted you and
you don't F you can agree with me
councilor stamp does no I do we always
used to have something in there and it
used to say because of sensitive
information or because of and I think
chairman just by virtue of the fact that
on this occasion it's lacking uh
chairman um I think that gives weight to
the fact that yes this should be okay I
take your point counc F I'm going to ask
officers for their reasoning for why
this needs to be PNC don't know who
wants to deal with it do you want me to
answer that or you okay yeah okay um I
think the reason for it
um uh B Mar is not for public um wider
publication is to the commercial
sensitivity of the um cost information
that is linked to one specific um
provider um which is not necessarily
that level of detail that's in the
public domain in respect of that that
that Leisure provider in terms of this
detail so I think um that that is the
reason why it's deemed to be
commercially sensitive um
so could confirm then if a a data access
request was submitted under the freedom
information act could you explain why
that information would not be imparted
by the council because I don't see it as
commercially sensitive I I see it as a
core piece of information which should
be available to the
public M Lucas
yes um no not at all I suppose um I
would may I might have to take that way
in consider it um I suppose on the
balance of the um VI of the committee
tonight um you may want to on the side
of caution because I don't want to give
you wrong advice and and consider it
under um uh PNC um as I say it's not
really our it's it's not information
that we own as such because it it
relates to a um uh place's Leisure and
their and their commercial information
so um whether if it was um requested
under an foi um whether it's it's an our
gift to share that that information that
is something I would have to double
check so I can't give you an absolute um
guarantee on that tonight so I think it
would be up to you to decide on the
balance of um a risk whether you want
you want to consider it under PNC or not
well councilor flea the decision whether
to exclude the press and public is a
democratic one so I'm going to ask if
there is a proposal for the exclusion of
public and press on in relation to I I
assume you're happy for item 12 so for
item
11 that the uh press and public be
excluded from discussions about item 11
I need a proposer that can you confirm
on what grounds chairman under the ACT
thank you've heard that councilor fluka
commercial the officer has stated
commercial
sensitivity thank you um that is
proposed by councelor Sidle is there a
seconder
can I can I ask a question chair yes to
place a quick one honestly um was it not
consulted with the mon um with Mr quelch
at at the pre- agenda
meeting um I can't answer that um it was
yeah
um so was that a seconding for councelor
Thompson so we have a proposal I I don't
think we need to go into this anymore
it's very straightforward we have a
proposal that the press and public are
excluded for item 11 proposed by
councelor Sidle seconded by councelor
Thompson those in
favor one one two three 4 five six those
against three okay so the press and
public are excluded for item
11 Tara can you confirm
when